did you guys see Joe Rogan with Sanjay
Gupta yesterday yes that was he really
called him which he never does yeah he
went on the offensive for maybe I've
been listening to Rogan for five years
yeah I've never seen him go on the
offensively I thought it was impressive
the way he asked the question he says so
do you feel at risk when you go out and
you know do your thing and you play you
know live your life it's just no because
I'm vaccinated he says great he says you
being vaccinated have the same amount of
risk as a kid that's not vaccinated but
why are we forcing kids to be vaccinated
because out of millions of kids only
five 500 kids have died and so you have
the same ratio risk why would we force
the kids to get vaccinated and he didn't
have an answer he was stuck because you
know in California
he kept trying to Pivot also but Joe
wouldn't let him he wouldn't let
Bulldogs said yesterday it was great
yeah but I got to give uh Gupta credit
for getting out there taking the tough
questions he he felt like
Joe at the beginning of the interview
was like how do you feel working for a
network that lies look yeah and and to
group those credit he's like yeah they
they shouldn't have said that and then
Joe pressed them and pressed him
wouldn't admit that they lied something
that you say all the time is like
something that's a lie of omission
something that Trump does is he'll get
on
opposite polarizing views and still
State his case
I get that but if you go on a posing
platforms and still lie on those
platforms you don't get rid of them it's
a liable Mission it's very simple did
they lie about invermectin well no no
well did well no that's not true he says
no he owned up to they said they
shouldn't have said that yeah but then
he refused to talk about what's it feel
like about the network he refused to
talk about the network consistently
lying he refused that's a tough
situation to be in he's not that's it
the whole thing with line the whole
thing with lines CNN line yesterday uh
uh uh van Jones flat out I don't know if
you guys saw van Jones yesterday Ronaldo
I'm a fan of Van Jones as well although
van Jones was a card carrying you know
communist years ago and all this stuff
you know when he was first linked to
Obama they had to pull him out and say
hey we can't affiliate with you
Evangeline yesterday said listen the
honeymoon is over Biden's getting
crushed okay and if they continue this
way it's not going to happen he says the
Republican is United Republic Republican
parties united right now with Congress
every one of them voted the same way
they just said not not a single
Republican voted against the uh what do
you call what is foreign debt ceiling he
says but the Democrats are in shambles
right now okay and and if they go the
way they're going right now it's not
going to be a good midterms it's not
going to be this he says they have 12
months to fix it but then Chris Cuomo
said the following Chris Cuomo said he
said van it doesn't matter anyways
because even if you guys go there the
opposing party is willing to lie to your
face just to get reelected they're
willing to compromise the Democracy of
America and Van Jones is the balls
that's Chris Cornell saying that so so
the point is on one and on the same
exact day when Rogan comes out with
Gupta saying yeah you know they
shouldn't have said that the network
light same day come was saying everybody
on the other side light so you know at
the end to be fair we could go on to Fox
News and find all the lives
there is do you okay this has got
nothing to do with the left or the right
this has got to do with the fact that
one says the other doesn't end the other
doesn't we don't that's the problem it's
like no no no we don't do it we're holy
but they do it no both of you have done
it and both of you have a hard time
coming out and saying I'm sorry we
screwed up so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]